الكميه ستدخل بالتدريج الان تستلم من قبل
الهلال الاحمر المصري تخزن في خزانات خاصه
بالوقود وستنقل الكميات تدريجيا لسد
الاحتياجات الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني هذه
هي
خطه ايصال الوقود
وبذات الديزل او السولار الى
ز
[موسيقى]
التحدي الاول اللي احنا واجهناه هو انه
هذه الشحنه الاولى من نوعها ان يتم التبرع
بها الحقيقه عن طريق الجمعيات الوطنيه
للهلال الاحمر والصليب الاحمر وهذا التبرع
جا من الحكومه العراقيه الممثله برئيس
الوزراء السيد محمد الشياع السوداني
واستجابه للاحتياجات
الانسانيه المحدده في نداء الاغاثه اللي
اطلق الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني تعرفون يعني
احنا
طبيعه المواد اللي ننقلها مختلفه تماما
مواد طبيه مواد غذائيه خيم بطانيات
تجهيزات منزليه مختلفه فكانت هذه هي المره
الاولى اللي نواجه بها كجمعيات وطنيه في
الهلال الاحمر العراقي الهلال الاحمر
المصري وكذلك الفلسطيني هذا النوع من
التبرع وكان هنالك تفاصيل لوجستيه كبيره
وكثيره
في عمليه النقل البحري التحميل المرور
متابعه السفينه خلال رحلتها ومن ثم وصول
الى
ميناء السويس وعمليه التفريغ هي بحد ذاتها
اي عمليه كبيره فالحمد لله انه هذه الجهود
تظافرت وبدعم من الحكومات الحقيقه الحكومه
العراقيه وايضا الحكومه المصريه
الممثله بسلطه ميناء السويس التي سهلت
عمليه المرور ساعدتنا كثيرا في
عمليات
التفريغ هنالك كان طلبات مقدمه من الجهات
الفلسطينيه لمجموعه من الاحتياجات وكان من
بينها هو الوقود
فالحكومة
وتعرفون انه الوقود هو تكسير حياه في هذه
اللحظات لانه بدون الوقود لا يمكن تشغيل
المستشفيات لا يمكن تشغيل سيارات الاسعاف
لا يمكن تشغيل مذاخر ومخازن الادويه لا
يمكن ايضا تشغيل الشاحنات التي تنف
المساعدات بدون الوقود كل شيء
[تصفيق]
سيتوقف كميات ستوجه الى الهلال الفلسطيني
والهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني سيستخدم هذه
الكميات لتشغيل مولدات المستشفيات لتشغيل
شاحنات نقل المواد الغذائيه والادويه
لتشغيل سيارات الاسعاف لتشغيل سيارات
الاغاثه هذه هي بالدرجه الاساس الكميه
موجهه لادام الحياه لسكان القطاء من خلال
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني وتعرف يعني خلال
هذه المرحله من النزاع وهو
مسلح دولي مثل ما تعرفون الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني معني
بتقديم الخدمات لسكان الاراضي المحتله في
غز